on dit clairement qu'on veut faire payer
leur juste part des outils riche des
milliardaires les gens qui ont une
partie gratuite depuis longtemps à cause
des partis conservateurs et libéraux ne
paie des propose de taxer les mieux
nantis de la société plusieurs
propositions en ce sens avec nous ce
soir de que tout
titulaire de la chaire de recherche en
fiscalité et en finances publiques de
l'université de sherbrooke mon soir
bonsoir la plus grosse promesse le
godbout du npdc l'impôt sur le
patrimoine net expliquez-nous mais
d'abord et risqué ça existe ailleurs
mais ça n'existe pas au canada une chose
est sûre et c'est pas très à la mode
dans les pays de l' ocde sur 37 pays
d'olt cdi en a seulement 5 qu'utilise un
impôt annuel sur le patrimoine net dont
la france mais dont le président
emmanuel macron arrêter ce n'est pas mal
l'assiette dans depuis son arrivée au
monde ça ne s'applique que sur les
propriétés immobilières et depuis les
années 80 il ya beaucoup de pays qui
l'ont laissé tomber trois pays
scandinaves notamment la suède
l'allemagne également donc c'est pour ça
que je dis que c'est pas la mode ok
alors si on avait ça est en fait ce que
propose le npd comment ça fonctionnerait
ça fonctionnera barre c'est un impôt
annuel c'est un impôt sur votre actif
familial on vous permet de calculer vos
actifs ont soustrait les passifs et on a
une extension sur le premier 10 millions
donc tous ceux qui à moins de 10
millions de patrimoine est n'est pas
visée par ce nouvel impôt pour ce qu'on
parle d'un impôts des riches et une fois
l'extension passé si vous avez 11
millions de patrimoine net vous allez
taxer sur un million au taux de 1%
annuellement essentiellement c'est comme
ça que ça fonctionne et combien ça
rapporterait les calculs ont été faits
par le directeur parlementaire du budget
ça rapporterait annuellement plus de 11
milliards de dollars ou 1,11 milliard en
c'est quand même pas mal 11 milliards
sur une année toutes avaient oui l'autre
promesse d'une pdc d'augmenter
l'imposition du gain en capital ce
serait se sent un changement important
que que d'augmenter le gain en capital
oui ou payer là sa frappe plus de monde
parce qu'il faut bien comprendre
si vous avez un dollar de salaire on
inclut le salaire dans votre revenu
imposable
mais si vous avez un gain en capital de
1 $ on inclut seulement 5 en dessous
dans votre revenu imposable double
avantage est hélas le tableau ce qui
nous montrait dans le fond c'est
l'évolution de l'inclusion du gain en
capital au fil des années avant 72 à
l'époque de nos grands parents c'était
le bon vieux temps leugueun cap town cas
pas du tout imposé il ya eu une grosse
réforme fiscale à 1972 donc de 72 ans 87
c'est la moitié du gain en capital qui
rentrait dans votre revenu imposable les
progressistes conservateurs de brian
mulroney l'on fait passer aux deux tiers
aux trois quarts en 1990 et le
gouvernement les gouvernements chrétien
jusqu'à 2000 l'ont laissé à 75% ensuite
un but deux dans l'année 2000 vous
constatez qu on est passé de 75 à 66 50
dans la même année paul martin a fait
chuter le taux d'inclusion par trois
fois et depuis ce temps là personne n'a
touché à l'inclusion nous sommes à 50
pour ça je vous montre historique je
vais vous dire il propose 75 pour ça ça
s'est déjà vu dans le passé ok mais pas
longtemps mais ça rapporterait convient
d'aller à 75 ça rapporterait autour de 9
milliards 9 milliards 3 le polonais à
chaque année mais pour l'année 2022 le
npd propose trois autres hausses
d'impôts notamment la hausse du taux
d'imposition le plus élevé supérieur
c'est bien ça on se rappellera que
justin trudeau l'avait déjà élevé de 29
à 33 % en 2015 le npd propose de le
passer de 33 à 35% et donc c'est un
ajout si on cumule puis on regarde ça
avec le taux combiné pour un québécois
le taux maximum passera 55 pour ça donc
ça c'est quand même un changement qui
rapporterait à peu près 700 millions par
année là ok
impôts sur le revenu des sociétés qui
augmenterait également petit rappel le
taux de 15% est en vigueur depuis 2002
en 2010 le taux était de 18% je ne parle
pas de la pertinence mais je peux juste
dire ce tour est de 18 pour ça jo a
existé en 2018 le npd propose de leur
béton on parle de quand même 5 milliard
et demi de rentrées fiscales par ce
changement et cette curiosité de taxes
rétroactive sur les profits
excédentaires ça c'est plus complexe
alors ça ce qu'il faut faire pour bien
comprendre c'est on on regarde d'abord
faut déterminer pour chaque entreprise
s'ils ont des profits excédentaires donc
pour déterminer sur la moyenne depuis
2014 et 2019 quelle était la moyenne de
leurs profits s'ils ont un profil
dentaire il devrait payer un taux de 15%
pour les années 2020 et 2021 pour les
entreprises qui ont plus de 10 millions
de profits et ça ça rapporterait quand
même c'est plus un one shot sais plus ce
que nous pourrons trouver une fois
unique mais presque 15 milliards de
dollars presque 15 milliards pour une
fois c'est pas récurrents bien sûr est
ce que est ce que toute démesure comme
ça que le npd veut m puis j'avais
calculé que c'est à peu près 150
milliards qu'on va aller chercher sur
cinq ans là est-ce que tout à coup si
jack meeting était le premier ministre à
la tête d'un gouvernement néo-démocrate
y aura une fuite des capitaux en disant
non non non on veut pas payer tout ça
fait des capitaux je ne sais pas mais
modification des comportements j'en suis
à peu près à c'est certain il ya des
mesures plus facile à faire que d'autres
comme on l'a vu mais mais mais puis le
directeur budgétaire a estimé chacune de
ces mesures c'est peut-être le train de
mesures qui ferait que ce serait
beaucoup à passer en une seule fois ou
en un seul mandat imaginez les comités
des finances où toutes les comités pour
lequel n'est pas les parties mais les
contribuables les entreprises se fera
entendre pour dire c'est beaucoup trop
en trop peu de temps ce serait toute une
réforme en effet merci à une révolution
ouais c'est ça la révolution fiscale
merci les ordres pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici
et redit